[Musik]
nehmen wir sie ja recht klein aus
wer häufig kannst du mal was für dich
nochmal 5 hallo herzlich willkommen sli
fällt heute habe ich eine praktikantin
an meiner seite der heute vielleicht die
komplette ausbildung machen beenden
hallo ich muss jetzt endlich hat den
backshop aber ich habe oft gebacken
das heißt den ofen rein nach zehn
minuten mit wasserspielen und dann raus
nehmen ja so alte sachen wieder frisch
machen
ja das kann man eine woche verkaufen
ok also an wird mir heute tatkräftig zur
seite stehen
backen heute eine tiramisu tat ja wir
machen erstmal was wasser webtrekk ist
aus mürbeteig macht man zum beispiel
auch kekse und plätzchen den keks teig
[Musik]
gesagt dass butter ich habe doch mit
papa früher als kind zu weihnachten ja
unsere mütter besteht eigentlich nur aus
drei zutaten sondern 1233 kein teil
super zweiteiler butter drei teile mehr
und bekommt noch dazu wenn man den
kundengeschmack salz auch noch ok hebt
immer so den süßen geschmack und wir
stellen immer am anfang meiner zutaten
vor also erstmal hier die zutaten für
den mürbeteig also für den mit graphen
wir 100 gramm zucker 200 gramm kalte
butter 300 gramm mehl etwas mannel
extrakt 2 eigelbe und eine prise salz
redest du eigentlich mit deinen leuten
hinterher kann man hier ja das war ja
schon nah dran und für mir
aber das machen wir schon also wird es
wir machen das schon gedanken gut ich
habe mir gedacht wir machen das jetzt
mal ohne küchenmaschine denn ich denke
dass bestimmte keine küchenmaschine und
du wirst bestimmt zu hause die tat nach
backen ja deswegen war heute alles von
kampfmaschinen oder kitchen wohin wird
als ihr könnt jetzt mit dem knethaken
machen mit dem handrührgerät oder ihr
nehmt eine küchenmaschine mit dem flach
hörer oder mixer oder die hände wir
machen mit den händen heute dann brauche
ich eine schüssel machen das direkt
ihren erstmal mail und der website wurde
früher auch hack teig genannt weil man
dann mit dem messer so zerhackt hat
wollitz medien vorgenommen ich wusste
ich glaube wir mal kurz als bei der
jetzt schon sagt klar und wir backen
heute die tat gleichzeitig also aaron
lärms tatsächlich direkt am ersten tag
gleich mit zucker reihen
ja zucker ist sehr gut jetzt machst du
so eine kleine mulde ein vulkan vulkan
da mache ich das alles mache erst mal
die butter ach so da muss das ja eine
große wunde seite und während die hände
noch sauber sind auch schon mal vanille
extrakt
ein extrakt nimmt man dann überhaupt zum
telefon halben das ist jetzt schon
ziemlich aufgebraucht aber ich brauche
neues wo kriege ich das denn her wie ich
doch mal direkt zu lieben weil die lohnt
sich das wissen und die wirken ja das
recht okay jetzt kann man mir gesagt
entweder so ein messer nehmen oder eben
eine tankkarte dass die da schneidet man
sich auch nicht trauen deswegen ist die
ganz praktisch und da kannst du denn die
butter stückchen zerhacken dafür und bei
mürbeteig ist wichtig da muss kalt
bleiben deswegen geben jetzt nicht mit
den fingern dran sondern bezahlen die
kläger dafür erwärmen wird genau und den
teig soll kalt bleiben damit die kekse
also der keks teig schön knusprig bleibt
schön mürbe
[Musik]
ja immer so ein bisschen mehr drauf und
da sagen das hast du nicht rein gemacht
mit keine cookie torte das immer wieder
gerne bereit oder auch wenn du dann so
weit bist mit den händen kurz nach
helfen aber so dass verdrecken branche
voll lecker jetzt ist deine meinung wer
ist auf jeden fall nicht sich gut und
ich war nicht stimmt wahrscheinlich
und dann wird der keltischen räume ja da
braucht es bisschen nur handwerker so
ein bisschen aber das schon so schön
gelb ja das sind die eigene person
dann muss man den eine stunde kalt
stellen und damit er schnell kühlt
drücke ich den immer flach und text ist
immer besser als das ist gut dann sehe
ich jetzt bis die menschen zu hause
machen was muss ich denn noch machen ich
fühle mich dort kniet man so ein
bisschen mit der mit dem handballen
nicht mit dem finger hand ich habe drei
monate im asyl gewährt was werden wir
die teenager bademeister und dann habe
ich abgebrochen
warum ich sagen es gibt die massage
harms podcast mutter nämlich die beste
heimteam
es gibt bei einer massage die startet
meistens bei der kanal fall der mauer
dekolleté und ich sagte also leider
massiert man in der lehre und auch im
kranken diesen seiten
sally bruder aaron sondern dann doch
eher die oma und opa
das war mir irgendwie völlig so bewusst
[Gelächter]
ich kann gut mit ihm reden aber nicht so
gut meistern haben stand ein sattes
kaufmann gelernt
jetzt da ich feierlich war die mutter
jetzt hat er doch schon sagen ja sie
doch gut das war gold wert wenn jetzt
noch genau alle alles rein alle zutaten
noch rein
die marke ist mega notiert mal irgendwo
und immer mehr mit dem handballen ich
bin finger okay schont auch so ein
bisschen die gelenke toter noch nicht
wie sie jeden tag wachsen und fondant
knetet und mit haben wir schon
die franzosen zeigen von da die angst
haben wir jetzt ist hier wieder alles
das geht schon noch rein der bäume so
ein bisschen zuneigung bist du schön
aber ich frage mich auch was bei dir
klar dass du besser bist aber dass ich
so viel schlechter ab und das geht jetzt
nur um das knie
es geht jetzt nicht um rechnen oder
suchen hast schon so buck basics mit
teig herstellen und das ist eine
bonitäts am ende ja was machen wir oben
drauf da kommt eine mascarpone creme
eine cafe creme du trinkst kein café max
noch kein kaffeegeschmack ok dann lasst
mit dem bei dir weg die zweite show qi
geschmack ja es geht ja immer noch nicht
das sieht gut aus kommt jetzt ich drücke
es immer einfach weil das muss jetzt
cool und dann geht es besser für mich
das immer
ich finde noch keinen unterschied ich
find auch mich ja jetzt hier noch ein
deckel raus vorsicht schienbein ja so
und da machen wir jetzt hier kurz sauber
und kühlen den teig für eine stunde der
herr möge scarlett jetzt geht es mit der
tat weiter und die tat bekommt ihr eine
schöne füllung bei mir kaffee füllung
bediener heißt schokoladen für sehr gut
ja okay dafür nehmen wir 50 g weiche
butter 100 g zucker 2 eier 250 gramm
quark 20 gramm stärke einen esslöffel
cacau genau du nimmst 100 milliliter
milch ich nehme 100 milliliter kaffee
und bei dir noch zum verfeinern bonbon
tonkabohnen passt passt oder bei mir war
mein zuschauern ist auch so ich mache
oft passt oder gerne was mit kaffee und
die frage was ist die alternative als
alternative könnt ihr immer heißer
schokolade als auch nie mit so einem
ding gearbeitet jetzt wirklich erst
jetzt muss ich mich schwach nur ein
handrührgerät ich habe auch zwei linke
hände ich kann nicht mit einer
bohrmaschine zu arbeiten
ach so dass es vorwärts rückwärts wenn
du später irgendwann mal keine ahnung
haus kind kegel muss die fotos können
nicht heute gelangen dadurch jetzt ich
sagen weil ich kann es nicht durch dich
kann ich kann da windelwechsel also
kannst du schaffst du wirklich als
alternativer unglücklichen der fenster
bei seiner puppe mal ausprobieren
ok am besten erst abschalten wenn es
drin ist was mach ich jetzt
die mutter klara und schaue was ist das
eine löffel ablage dass dein
arbeitsplatz aber bleibt letztlich von
mir ist von dem partner wie ich finde
was ist alles gibt darauf kommt es ja
sonst nur okay es drin dann zucker rhein
nun erst einschalten wenn du zurück
geräte ins ruhigere drei gestattet
ja
langsam starten langsam starten
da gibt es jetzt die ehre zu eins nach
dem anderen
also ein rein rutschen lassen einrühren
und das nächste das letzte käsekuchen
hoffe dass andere renault
ich kann ehrlich sagen wenn du alles
vorbereitet wird und schöner
arbeitsmaterialien hat machte richtig
spaß
[Musik]
und dann können jetzt alle anderen
zutaten rein und ich was mache ich denn
hier kann man die stellen so hin hier
mag speisestärke bei mir der kaffee ach
gleich alles jetzt einmal ist alles rein
und kakao und dann mit dem rühren
langsam anfangen denn da kann es
passieren dass etwas rausspringen
ok
passiert
[Applaus]
haye macht spaß
ja das ist ganz schön das letzte mal
dass ich eigentlich mit suchen meistens
voll zu tun hatte war ich auf einer
abfahrt gut dann stellen wir das zur
seite machen preetz auber und hole den
teig zum ausrollen wie der teig dann
muss es raus geholt werden und kommt in
form war doch ein bisschen viel butter
drauf das wird aber auch aus harry
potter naja gut beherrsche richtig man
probiert die reha ich mache es jetzt zum
ersten mal habe einfach das rezept so
macht sie auch so
in der theorie immer zusammengehören
sagt ist jetzt acht dafür dass dich
reich zu nein das ist ein dass die
kinder unterstützt der ring
ich nehme die aufgabe ja ja das ist
brauch euro heute nicht weil ich nicht
dunkel so ok habe ich gott das ist die
tat vor da kommt unser kuchen rein und
jetzt nehmen wir ein bisschen mehl muss
er nicht haben wir dann schon draußen
will und tolkmitt holen
das war meiner ich weiß dass ich sage
mal lang mal ich finde meinen besser was
gut ist und jetzt jetzt raus holen
wieder geht es ja schon wieder kaputt
seitdem ist mir ein bisschen kneten und
der muss es ein bisschen warm werden
dass werden aus rollen können für alle
vier sind karte oder schweizer mit der
gezackten ja hab ich hab' ich hab ich
hier mit dem kneten das schon so der
anstrengende partie richtig kalten teig
zu kneten
eigentlich müsste schon so abraham wieso
eine italienische oben
von harter job und so was mache ich
dreifach parallelen an einem tag wissen
ist die zuschauer dass wir mehrere dinge
auf einmal drinnen nähe
[Musik]
ich finde es einfach dass du so viele
videos auf einmal bringen kannst du ja
mit dem kopf bei der pizza die wir auch
machen wenn jetzt muss ich wie auch
immer wieder kuchen zaubern überbrücke
ich immer die wartezeit die kühe zeit
schon immer gemacht oder stand ist
früher mal so eine stunde rum doch das
können wir derzeit noch ein anderes ich
war schon immer zeit immer auf
zeitersparnis oder in der zeit machte
den haushalt das bisschen 280 männer
dann so schön rund ist okay ich habe
hier noch so ein fakt renz behörde
auswahl sehe ich den wein oder
tschuldigung das gas nicht gemerkt wie
sagte gesagt ähnlich aus könnte man es
auch machen mehr klar
danke auch gut gehen immer dass ich mit
meinen haben ja jetzt arbeiten wir mit
wenig mehr und versuchen den teig rund
auszuräumen
die form ist 25 cm groß und du brauchst
du jetzt ungefähr 30 ab und deswegen
sind hier die zentimeter vor friedrich
und damit ich mache und damit eher
gleichmäßig wird es sind bei dir diese 5
mm ringe drauf dann wird er genau 5 mm
dick damit sollte man ein bisschen und
dresden damit auch schön rund wird
ich kann aber das holz sehen oder aber
wir nicht dass hier dreht dann klebt da
auch nicht das tun sie ist doch immer ob
genug mehl noch drunter ist
ich bin jetzt schon bei 25 cm
sollte es noch nicht rund
ach so ja ich hab ich vergessen nach
oben und unten müssen ja 25 erst alle
richtungen das kann man so machen
es wird unterschieden es ist mehr
drunter schieber dieser moral mehr
unterschiede
ok wenn sie flach
mir ist das öl des backens nicht jetzt
und dann nimmst du das hier drauf wenn
es die form und pax den da rein und wenn
es reißt ist nicht schlimm
gut passt perfekt rein und dann schön
oder machen sagt man hier auch so die
flickarbeiten genau so wenn er reist
kann zu flickarbeiten machen
und dann kannst du nämlich mit so einer
palette den rand wegnehmen wo finde ich
denn jetzt um dass ich die wieder kaputt
machen jeder geht nicht klappt es mit
einer band perfekt
also ist es kein unterschied nicht ja
auch nicht ich finde das sehr gut aus ja
doch alles schön
und jetzt stellen wir den so ein
bisschen ein dass er nicht hoch packte
löcher rein mit dem und diesmal packen
wir den teig gar nicht vor sondern
füllen indirekt damit die käsemasse auch
direkt mit backen naja jetzt raus und
jetzt gibt's auch sie sich mit 14
das können wir ja ich hoffe dass nicht
zu tiefe löcher gemacht hast da projekt
schätzt die füllung nicht unten geht
ich bin guter bauarbeiter ich weiß immer
mein fuß zu beheben dann füllt sich das
da rein
[Musik]
ok dann kommt die tat jetzt in den
backofen vorsicht das ist ein hebel
boden also wenn jetzt unten hältst mich
hochdrücken sonst bricht dieser seite
sehr gut komme ich nach dem einem
backofen auf danke vorsicht backofen
nicht verbrennen
ich finde es schön aus hast du zwei
natürlich draußen
ich war mir die hände was passiert mit
dem rest machen wir machen keks
noch mal so einen großen keks ja ein
bisschen mehr drauf gastieren uns
vorliegen haben ja jetzt gut druck
einfach so den stempel einer canon bis
zum boden will
geil
es gibt sixt
die nazis haben die die senioren von
senioren zocken gemacht peter der peter
folgten nämlich unbedingt kekse backen
peter bei mir gibts sowas nicht und dann
habe ich ihm den stempel gegeben war
auch glücklich
muss ich das jetzt so weg nein es geht
um ein glas wasser
ich mache das was ich nicht gut
oder ein aussteiger ich kann ja
ausstecher geben und dann rannte die
airline kindergarten ganz schnell was
gesagt hat
bei mama war sein jahr zog der markt mit
denen herrscht gebacken persönliches
gespräch
was ist alles hilfen gibt dem menschen
wenn immer fauler früher haben wir das
alles so gemacht
jacada was machst du hast ihn klein hält
die kann man auch sehen was ist es jetzt
auch kekse aha sind verschiedene muster
jetzt was ist alles gibt gemacht von die
resteverwertung so viel wie du bugs und
kurzwahl müssen nun nicht nicht nach
nicht okay machst du das fragen ja du
bist ja top in form und ich kann doch
nicht die ganze zeit und wenn kleine
schweinchen
wenn man bill buck dann hat man keine
lust aufs essen dann warten wir jetzt
bis die tat geraten ist und dann 30
minuten und da können wir später noch
die bahamas capone kremann röhren
da kommt noch was drauf ja heute voll
ist kompliziertere projekt auch wieder
so ein rutschej reiser gehörte
stabilisiert so die tat ist fertig
gebacken die ist abgekühlt und habe den
kühlschrank gestellt
und jetzt kommt obendrauf meine
mascarpone creme zur sonne tiramisu tat
deswegen muss mascarpone schon sein
und dafür haben jetzt schon zutaten
nämlich 50 gramm puderzucker 250 gramm
als capone 250 gramm sahne und sonderbar
zum steif schlagen
wer möchte kann auch amaretto dazu geben
muss aber nicht okay ist das genau das
ist das hier nur einmal um gefällt und
wir machen alles räume erst mal nur die
mascarpone und der machen wir alles
genau den puderzucker noch dazu
ich habe heute so viele sachen die wo
ich weiß dass es umkippte
aber da ändern kann für die später von
ihm als capo das schmeckt es nicht so
gut
das heißt so ein frischkäse das heißt
auch der maske wohl nicht vergessen der
mystery und noch mehr an puderzucker
kurz früher bis dieses verbundes uns ja
erst später oder studios hat mir zum
praktikum jeder tag wird mit einem
wischmopp pendelt am ende des
arbeitstages muss die küche sorge sein
und der wohnung und alle zutaten
verräumen das ist nicht schlecht werden
das ist nicht normal doch dann kriegst
auch den ausbildern schein ok und dann
kannst du langsam die sahne dazu gießen
schön langsam warum langsam damit sich
gut verbindet mit der maschine
gucken genau was ich da keine klumpen
bilden
dann nehmen wir ein aparter zu
viereinhalb dass das ein apparat den
steillagen dass es alleine drei jetzt
auch aber so bleibt es länger
standhalten
deshalb gestrichen genau weil direkt
messbar
das finma sieht schon gut bei musik und
cremiger hausparty auch dann ruhig alles
vom rand mit
allerdings müsse man hat so lange wird
dann ist kaputt ja ja jetzt guckst du
hat das läuft noch so ein bisschen was
noch ein bisschen damit
doch manchmal vielleicht noch ein
bisschen hier also weiter aber auch noch
ein bisschen weiter
[Musik]
das ist so geil das schmeckt wie die
gute die man auf dem kuchen auf macht es
gibt jetzt in den supermärkten nur noch
dieses öko variante wo kein zucker drin
ist wo das ist das schöne kacke und dies
gut geschlagen
ich kann das ganze in spritzbeutel
einfach besser dem etwa meine diät auch
vergessen er sah nach zwei beste so ne
gute schlagsahne habe ich lange nicht
mehr gemacht spritzbeutel einzelhilfe ja
jetzt weißt du was passiert ist letzten
13 jahren aber das ist wirklich das hört
sich aber gut gehalten
beim wild sache 30 kilo in zehn jahren
und do 18
aber ich war damals du bist ja eben bin
ja auch mal da ist okay so aber du hast
mir gesagt da gibt es das und dann mache
ich das
das schneiden wir vorher noch ab
ich habe von solchen gesprächen über
opel ist jetzt die das tipps oder
umdrehen was nichts draus machen knicken
gibt's oben umstülpen ja da kannste
einfühlen ohne das ist halt man muss das
schon fragt er mich diesen löffelte
wieder und wohl auch weil genau weil wir
beide hände frei hast kannst du die
schüssel hoch nehmen kann aber auch nur
machen weil der konditor den ganzen es
gibt ja auch wieder kompakt ist einfach
schön jetzt den beutel zusammen drehen
sowohl wundern hier das ende zusammen
aber ich will dann kannst du das mal
hier halten
ja und ich muss es doch fix weiter
runter jetzt möglich mit gefühl und wir
zwar muss ja so und jetzt zeigt dann
kannst du es jetzt ablegen man kann doch
immer schön abwägen wo mit der stützung
so manches mal von der arbeitsplatte und
sonja regel nummer eins alles muss immer
gleich weg ist gesund mit gesunder milch
erst einmal probiert
das war meine ja nee das ist gut aus
wirklich das hat eine und jetzt hätte
den spritzbeutel so aufrecht ja die
haben es drückt die creme raus rechts
oder linkshänder recht wo jetzt einfach
alles voll machen
[Musik]
aber ich glaube dass ich habe aber zu
wenig ja noch ein bisschen größere
tupfen
ok also wenn du keine häufchen sondern
das muss ich machen sie mit bauschaum ja
hallo auf den boden gekleckert zu
probieren
ja ich hab ihr denn hier wird außerdem
von den klicks draufgemacht toll die
ganze optik zerstört manche probieren
machen
diabetes ist hübsch beide schöne gezeigt
dann kann man jetzt eigentlich
sie hat den er den nimmt daran mit für
zuhause hier gekauft tiramisu preis drin
in diesem team heiß trocken und damit
nicht auf einmal so viel kakao rauskommt
das ist so posiert rauskommt darauf will
ich bin nicht ich habe früher immer in
meinem backshop habe ich immer wenn so
die show cupertino zu alle angesehen
braunau wohnen habe ich gemacht und
dabei ein richtig und dann sind wir
fertig dann müssen wir die tat steht das
untendrunter
[Musik]
was für ja mach mal dann richten was an
sarah darf bilder machen für die hände
hoch ja mit der hand genau dann darüber
haben darüber dann darfst du net orten
verkauft und zum präsentieren mit dem
silbernen
ja bitte ok kriegst du vielen dank
möchtest du schön dass er meinen torten
drehteller als torten ständer
das ist doch kanzler machen dass ich die
leute die jetzt über das ging mit drauf
guck mal das ich das du über slime genau
und du bist zum abwaschen ernst die
schöne hilfe ist auf diesem boden drüber
und vollständig hauen allein jetzt nur
beim zugucken von fenja ich kann das
auch nicht sehen ich kann sagen ich war
sogar einer tiefgarage nur ein kreis
montag ist schlecht
ich halte den rekord bei galileo am
meisten brechen einen beitrag ein alter
wagen getestet und ich habe dieses buch
nicht gelesen perfekt mal die platte
nehmen wir noch drunter aber
selbstverständlich ist der bruder zu
gast heute ich freue mich darüber
und jetzt wo es um krieg zwar kosten
hieß ja
[Musik]
er leiht geht's amstad verkosten welche
tat willst du probieren also dies mit
kaffee und dies mit schokolade doch ich
meine jetzt anschneiden ihr papier
liefert die vom ahorn okay wie diese mit
der show plötzlich kein kaffee drin
ja genau dies für erwachsene und schon
probiert sagt trainer schwingen café du
machst den ersten spiel ich bin gespannt
mit wem ich bin gut mit zog richtig gut
richtig cool und magier am herd ich
probiere auch maxi mit kaffee probieren
oder nicht sie hatten probleme aber ich
mag die apfel
wer kann mitmachen zu wollen
das ist ein guter weiß was da so gut ist
die tonkabohne diese dieses aroma ja das
passt so gut zu schokolade also du hast
schöne tonkabohnen schokoladentafeln
ja und ich habe für die erwachsenen eine
kaffeepause gemacht und er lag dann da
und gut backen
ja das war für die kinder oder für die
erwachsenen als ob du darfst du ich
ehrlich sagen ich bin auch nicht sauer
oder so oder auch nicht so ich bin auch
nicht traurig wenn dir meins nicht
schmeckt du kannst ruhig sagen dass sie
das mit kaffee nicht geschmeckt hat und
man darf seine ehrliche meinung sagen
man muss ja niemanden damit verletzten
[Musik]
du süße maus sehr gut was holen
ich habe nämlich noch was für nahrung
erfahrt ihr gleich den haarsträhnen ist
zwar einmal komplett um meinen kopf
gewickelt muss noch kurz was holen denn
ich wollte den aufführungen er hat ja er
hat das ja echt gut gemacht heute den
muss sagen ich bin echt stolz auf dich
danke ich auch auf mich aber ich würde
es nie wieder machen
ashraf nie dein job ist wer denkt dass
paypal ist so anstrengend werden doch
nur zwei rezepte heute war anstrengend
ich hole schnell was ich komme auf das
fertig ist marvin möchtest du ein
bisschen jackie
ich meine wenn man bei mir schon
praktisch gemacht dann bekommt man durch
auch eine urkunde
wie bei den bundesjugendspielen ist
keine note oder so aber wie bei den
bundesjugendspielen zur teilnahme
erfolgreich da ja echt gut gemacht gab
es bei euch damals die
bundesjugendspiele ja und wie war es so
bei der nortel gab es zwei mal und ich
war zweimal verletzt weil man so
erfolgreiche teilnahmen
sportlich gewesen doch ja kriegs nämlich
heute in der urkunde für die erfolgreich
abgeschlossen das praktikum einmaleins
des backens einmaleins des kochens
einmaleins des zwiebelschneiden
handrührgerät führerschäin hast du
gesunder pausensnack für kinder muss er
noch beurteilen hat dein haus und snack
geschmeckt hat das gut gemacht was
gesund ok und auskratzen vorbei weil das
ganz eigenständig ausgekratzt ja herr
müller unterschreibt ist jetzt auch klar
und schreibe ich dir noch wer braucht so
und dann haben wir das jetzt hier gleich
ein und dann kommt es im büro
ja guck mal da kamen wir rutschen dich
mal darüber mit einer torte
also hat rausgeholt dankeschön
herzlichen glückwunsch vielen dank geil
da freue ich mich hast du nicht einmal
bitte für die presse aber kein foto für
die presse
dort geglückt pizza haben wir auch noch
gebacken in einem anderen video schaut
euch gerne an
würdest du dich hart nach backen und
würzig essen und ich finde sie gut aber
schon echt guten kochen backen ist
anstrengend ich bin froh dass ich nur
klamauk macht einfach spaß zum
nachbacken bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
du es gerne kochen nicht gern ja es
blühte mir jetzt noch mal zwei videos
gemacht gekocht und gebacken jetzt wird
noch aufgewischt gekürzt küche
einsortiert lebensmittel versorgen das
heißt als team verteilen alle
lebensmittel lebensmittel gerechtfertigt
ja und dann noch kinder wird folgen
nachhilfe unter mir rat noch klavier und
wir müssen noch packen für
fernsehwerbung weiter geht so lohse da
kommt